have you ever gone to the supermarket
and realized that you spent more money
than you intended to
the primary goal of any supermarket is
that it wants its customers to spend
more time and more money without really
asking them to do so how is this
possible
well the answer lies in the structure or
the design of the supermarket store
whenever we enter any supermarket we see
trolleys kept prominently in front of
our eyes
why it's because even if the customer is
coming to purchase just one product the
trolley in her hand will make her
purchase more products just to fill up
the trolley and not be embarrassed at
the cash counter
in the initial sections we find perfumes
and beauty products for freshness which
also set the mood of the customers for
an immersive shopping experience
quite often we find the groceries
section placed at the corner or the end
of the store why is that
that's because before buying the
essential items they want the customers
to explore the store and purchase the
not so essential items
also we will never really find windows
or clocks in a supermarket to our
surprise the reason here is to make
customers escape from the real world and
not make them realize about the
excessive time that they're spending
there
and children love chocolates right which
is why chocolates are kept at the bottom
section so that children can easily grab
them and place them in the trolley
also while going to the billing counter
we find some irresistible tiny products
kept there the supermarket wants us to
top up the shopping cart with these
products even when we are paying the
bill
[Music]
have you heard of supermarkets with no
checkouts
read the first comment to know more